So now you know the process
of building an engaging game.
And you have insight into how game
design can keep players returning
to your game.
>> So what do you think with
key takeaways from this lesson.
<< I think the most important
thing I learned is,
that there's no one way to monetize a
game or get your players engaged in it.
But to make a great game, you always
want to keep your audience in mind and
choose the best game pace for them.
>> Yeah.
Building a game so
it gets more difficult over time and
involves friendly competition is a great
way to keep your game interesting.
>> And keeping players interested and
having high player retention
is the main way a game will
make money and not fizzle out.
>> Besides game pace we also
made sure that our game was
easy to use across devices by saving
all our data into the cloud and
building in an easy restart mechanism.
>> And finally we talked
about how to get a fan base
who can help you promote your game
through social networks and outreach.
>> A couple of times we've also
mentioned ways to make money in your
game through in app ads,
purchases and so on.
But we'll talk about this in
more detail in the next section
which is all about
monetization strategies.